An interesting application of MapReduce and these design patterns
is making top N record lists. These are especially useful
if you work at a company like BuzzFeed. But even
if you don't, you still might want to use these. And
in this question we're going to, in particular, find the top
ten longest forum posts. Now, with a relational data base
management system you just first sort your data. In this
case forum posts. And then pick the top N records.
But with MapReduce, this just won't work. The
data isn't sorted and it's processed in several machines.
So, instead, what we're going to have to do
is have each mapper generate a top N list
and then send these local lists to the
reducers who can then find the global top N.
It's sort of like what happens in the Olympics. If
you want to find the top three I don't know,
swimmers, every country needs to send their top three swimmers
to the Olympics. And then, through a competition, figure who globally
the top three swimmers are. Anyways, let's go ahead and find
the top ten longest forum posts in the Udacity forum data.